on this Wednesday night BC Port strike
drama while workers have again ditched
the picket lines
[Applause]
the pressure the feds face to end the
dispute
Russia's revenge for a bridge attack
the new strikes pummeling Ukraine
High Tech Health how AI could Aid in
diagnosing Alzheimer's and movie mashup
Barbie plus Oppenheimer what's going on
equals harbenheimer I thought I might
stay over tonight why I'm actually not
sure
yeah
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight Fara Nasser
an eerie silence blanket at Canada's
largest port today and with it hundreds
of millions of dollars worth of product
at a standstill at the Port of Vancouver
where a back and forth labor dispute is
disrupting operations for a third
straight week
good evening thanks for joining us after
a deal was thought to be in the books
last week uncertainty is once again
muddying the Waters of Labor
negotiations in British Columbia
the union leaders representing Port
workers rejected a federal mediator
settlement they could have put an end to
the 13-day work stoppage this morning
workers reissued a 72-hour strike notice
after a new walkout was deemed illegal
then late this afternoon that notice was
removed now it's not clear why more
details will come out of a union meeting
tonight arnita Garcia is at the Port of
Vancouver for us meet you
pharah BC's Premier David EBY said
Federal legislation is not the solution
at this stage and called on Ottawa to
help get the two sides back to the
bargaining table but stakeholders
including business groups are saying the
opposite and demanding for Ottawa to
bring this strike to an immediate end
this empty lot another twist in the BC
Port strike going back and forth
Picketts came down and strike action
stopped again
last week many thought the nearly
two-week long strike was about to end
until Tuesday when the union rejected
the tentatively agreed upon contract
with every day that the the port is
disrupted it takes several days to
recover on Tuesday Morning the resumed
strike action came to a halt after the
labor Minister announced a ruling for
the union to seize and desist from
participating in any strike action
because it did not provide 72-hour
strike notice and called the job action
illegal the economic impact of this this
dispute is about 800 million dollars a
day
so significant impact on the Canadian
economy really the third of North
America Canada's non-north American
Trade goes to the port of Vancouver
every day the employer said the union
then doubled down and issued another
72-hour strike notice which was removed
just hours later the reaction from
political leaders was Swift my patience
personal patience has run out we really
have a responsibility to act we should
produce as much as we can right here in
Canada right here in Ontario until we
don't have these issues Justin Trudeau
must do his job and end this strike
immediately because of the massive cost
to workers
consumers and businesses the Canadian
Federation of Independent Business says
70 percent of small businesses in BC
have been impacted by the job action and
a majority of businesses across Canada
feel Ottawa needs to end the strike we
do feel that Back To Work legislation is
now the only option that the federal
government may be left with the union
says it's been in a legal strike
position since July 1st and only
suspended picketing at the request of
the labor Minister and hopes to return
to the bargaining table to negotiate
Fair compensation and protection for
workers job security
Global News Vancouver
after months of uncertainty the province
of BC is ordering the city of Surrey to
transition to a Municipal Police Service
and to abandon plans to revert to the
RCMP BC solicitor general and Public
Safety Minister Mike farnworth says the
decision is final
the debate over policing in Surrey has
been highly charged and divisive
I know that this is an extraordinary use
of my powers under the police Act
and I did not make this decision lightly
farnworth is also promising to introduce
legislation in the fall to help ensure
similar policing sagas don't happen
again Serie mayor Brenda Locke calls the
ruling misguided based on inaccurate
assumptions and an undermining of a
local government
more help is on the way for firefighters
battling the more than 370 active
wildfires in British Columbia provincial
officials say 75 more military personnel
are heading to Burns Lake in northern BC
and they're going to join 75 others who
are already in the region as part of
federal government Aid North of
Cranbrook at least six homes have been
destroyed and dozens more evacuated
after a wildfire sparked Monday tripled
in size
foreign
s have joined the fire fight and parts
of Greece as Raging wildfires spread
Northwest of Athens hundreds of
firefighters and multiple water bombers
have been sent from around the continent
to help tackle several wildfires
thousands have been told to flee with
several homes already destroyed
scorching heat is gripping southern
Europe with temperatures in many cities
reaching record highs on Tuesday
in Ukraine it was a hellish Knight of
attacks in and around the southern port
city of Odessa for a second straight day
since Russia pulled out of that grain
deal
Ukraine's Air Force says Russia launched
31 missiles and 32 drones overnight
according to Ukraine Russia destroyed 60
thousand tons of grain meant for export
the Kremlin says ships Bound for Ukraine
will also be considered as hostile
here's Crystal gamensing
unverified videos on social media
captured a massive explosion reportedly
in the Port City
Russia says it hit military and
Industrial facilities around Odessa with
Precision strikes launched by air and
sea
no military hardware here just
Elizabeth's bedroom now littered with
glass and debris
we heard the first explosion then the
siren we quickly moved to the corridor
to be between two walls Ukraine says six
cruise missiles were fired towards
Odessa from the Black Sea but claim all
were intercepted officials say they also
took down 31 drones Tuesday night into
Wednesday
Russia is deliberately targeting
civilian infrastructure living quarters
and our ports of the Ukrainian president
adding the attack on the port threatens
Global Security because so many rely on
Ukraine's agricultural exports the
future of which is in limbo after Russia
pulled out of the deal ensuring
Ukrainian grain transports through the
Black Sea Russians meanwhile living in
occupied Crimea were also dealing with
the aftermath of strikes smoke was seen
billowing from an area said to be a
military training base roughly 2 000
people were sent to an evacuation Center
we're not pet I'm lying down 4 am an
explosion a flash of light five minutes
later another flash of light and then
the bombings says this man who was about
two kilometers away from the base Russia
has controlled Crimea since 2014 when it
illegally annexed the Ukrainian
Peninsula Now using it as a military
staging point
the Kremlin says the strikes are
retaliation for an attack Monday on the
bridge linking Russia and Crimea so more
strikes on Southern Ukraine are likely
Crystal commencing Global News London
in the U.S there are more signs of just
how deep efforts were to overturn the
2020 presidential election authorities
in Michigan have charged 16 Republicans
in a scheme to falsely certify Donald
Trump as the winner and the walls are
closing in on the former president as
well who could face charges over his
efforts to cling to power but as Jackson
prosco reports remarkably none of it
seems to be hurting Trump's push for a
new term
back on the campaign Trail the former
president previewed his legal strategy
deflect and deny we have prosecutors
that are evil people these are evil
people deranged though Donald Trump
claims his looming prosecution is
politically motivated his attempts to
overturn the 2020 election are no secret
we're going to walk down to the Capitol
from his words on January 6 2021 to
behind the scenes efforts to sway state
election officials many of whom have
already given evidence to a grand jury
convened by special counsel Jack Smith
they have to show that he actually knew
that he lost the election it has to be
shown that he had the requisite intent
to to try to impede the transfer power
when he knew in fact that the election
had been lost how do you feel reports
suggest Trump is likely to be charged
with deprivation of Rights conspiracy
and witness tampering just as other
election-related prosecutions are
gaining Steam
in Michigan officials have charged 16
Republicans who falsely signed paperwork
claiming Trump won the state in 2020
when he in fact lost this plan
to reject the will of the voters and
undermine democracy was fraudulent and
legally baseless Trump is the most
important Target for prosecutors making
him a martyr for Republicans he's still
Far and Away the front-runner for the
party's presidential nomination but in
the eyes of the general public his legal
woes may leave him a damaged candidate
many Americans think that these
indictments disqualify Trump for the
presidency as we see the accumulation of
bad news we're likely to see his popular
support continue to erode all of it
offers a window into another part of
Trump's legal strategy delay in the
Florida documents case Trump's lawyers
have asked for the trial to be postponed
until after the November 2024 election
if Trump is indicted again expect more
of the same
Jackson prosco Global News Washington
summer in Canada usually means time off
for vacations beaches and barbecues but
for political parties vying for your
vote times of change even when there's
no election looming politicians are in
constant campaign mode and they're
spending big bucks on digital strategies
to stay in your feed and get to know you
our chief political correspondent David
Aiken reports
on our screens tablets and phones
fifteen hundred dollars in a month yeah
on grocery bills this is camp adotzi in
Latvia these days the digital political
campaign never stops oh amazing we love
long-term care workers maintaining that
touch point on these social media
platforms constantly testing and making
sure that your audience is true will be
something that needs to be done on a
consistent basis you're out there
looking for supporters first of all and
once you ID them that they're supporting
you then you try to move them up the
ladder can they give money can they give
time political campaigns gather names
phone numbers postal codes the building
blocks of a voter database then they
take that to social networks like
Facebook for micro targeted campaigns to
find even more supporters our ability to
really match what we're seeing in public
opinion directly to the criteria that we
know were granted on these platforms
makes it extremely efficient to talk to
the right people even their opponents
can see that the Liberals are doing best
right now at digital campaigns the
Liberals are the you know the reigning
champ if you will when it comes to this
but they are getting old and tired can
Justin Trudeau recapture some of that
magic um you know eight years into his
mandate and and what is he doing to
attract new people Ken pierre-paulieu
translate some of that Twitter
aggressiveness that he's so good at that
he's perfected into something that's a
little bit softer perhaps to attract
more middle-of-the-road audiences Dave
summer once worked in prime minister
Justin Trudeau's office running liberal
digital campaigns people who will have
success at the next election are the
ones who are doing something a little
bit different than they're doing now the
big liberal Advantage is partly based on
the digital reach of its leader Justin
Trudeau his Facebook page for example is
followed by 8.5 million people the pages
of Pierre pauliev and jugmeet Singh have
about a million followers combined that
said all parties are constantly testing
new digital techniques and content is
more important than ever poliev is now
telling a story so you're seeing he may
not have the same route now I would say
his reach is actually quite large but he
is telling a narrative that is reaching
a certain segment of the population
political data and analytics is already
very sophisticated but the future is on
the horizon with artificial intelligence
tools like chat GPT that will make
collecting political data cheaper and
even more precise pharah
David Akin in Ottawa thank you for that
David
detecting a devastating brain disease
coming up how artificial intelligence
could be a critical tool in diagnosing
Alzheimer's
an Alzheimer's diagnosis is devastating
for any family and while there's no cure
an early diagnosis can make a difference
in managing symptoms and planning for
the future new technology using
artificial intelligence is offering hope
for detecting the disease earlier than
ever before Catherine Ward explains
well it's an honor to care for people
you love and it's hard and you you know
end that Journey with some scars that
stay with you Dr Sharon Cohen knows
firsthand how difficult it can be to see
the people you love slowly slip away
they developed Alzheimer's disease when
I was already a neurologist
studying dementia care her father Martin
was a mathematician and loved to play
the piano her mother Donya an author and
passionate poet there's nothing nice
about Alzheimer's and
I think of them a lot even though it's
too late for them I feel like they would
be thrilled to know there's something
for next Generations the disease is
tricky it's complex come on forward but
a new technology is showing significant
promise the goal is to get ahead of a
diagnosis and optometrists may have a
key role to play my role in this has
been to help screen patients especially
the patients over the age of 55 who have
some kind of memory loss or memory
changes the process will be familiar to
most of us just like having your eyes
checked a flash a few pictures and the
results are ready to be analyzed an AI
algorithm reads and analyzes the scans
the results are shared with family
doctors who help patients understand
them so if we look at the back of the
eye we're able to see the front part of
the brain and we can look for these
biomarkers and changes that may be
occurring in the brain the biomarker is
a protein it is the first measurable
sign of the disease so no clinician can
look in the back of your eye and
determine if you have the signs of
Alzheimer's disease but with the special
sensor that we use and the algorithm
we're able to with very strong
reliability uh determine who does and
does not have that protein the hope 's
for patients to also talk about changes
in their memory with their eye doctor
and
technology is not widely available and
still needs approval from Health Canada
developers say they would like to see it
rolled out by 2025. doctors say it's an
encouraging step forward for a disease
that has already taken so much this
provides huge hope for people that we're
not just trying to patch up symptoms
we're getting at the underlying disease
we can slow it down we can keep people
functioning longer keep them Wilder in
the community with their families keep
people with mild cognitive impairment at
that stage longer rather than having
them progress to dementia Catherine Ward
Global News Toronto
[__] ing for rights in Afghanistan ahead
the rare protests over a ruling from the
Taliban
dozens of women in Afghanistan on stage
a rare protest today after the Taliban
ordered the closure of beauty salons
across the country
come on
[Applause]
Security Forces use tasers and water
cannon to break up the demonstration
Taliban says it's outlawing salons
because the services they provide are
forbidden by Islam it is the latest
attack on the rights of women and girls
in the country since the Taliban
returned to power two years ago
a third round of violent clashes have
erupted in Kenya as protesters demand
the government lower the cost of living
several people have been shot by
security forces the opposition has
called for three days of countrywide
demonstrations to try and force the
president to repeal his new Finance act
and tax on housing and fuel that has
effectively pumped up the price of gas
to its highest ever level
[Music]
box office battle next the bizarre
summer showdown between two blockbusters
FIFA officially kicks off the Women's
World Cup in Australia and New Zealand
tomorrow and here at home excitement is
building for teen Canada's first match
against Nigeria tomorrow night Canada is
ranked seventh in the world but after
winning gold of the Tokyo Olympics two
years ago hopes are high according to
new exclusive polling for Global News 14
percent of Canadians believe the team
will actually win the World Cup
and there's another summer Showdown on
the horizon two of this year's biggest
movies hit theaters this week and they
couldn't be more different one is the
story of a children's toy come to life
while the other is about the creator of
the atomic bomb but as Mike Armstrong
explains somehow the Blockbusters have
been linked in a way unlike anything
we've seen in the film industry
hi Barbies
hi Ken
the battle at the box office this
weekend will be waged between a blonde
bombshell hi Ken and a brown-haired bomb
maker I have a 12-month Head Start 18.
how could you possibly know that
somehow the two movies have been linked
by harnessing the power of juxtaposition
there's something strange about putting
them together but people are what's
going on I'm actually not sure
this is one of the mashup trailers
taking Barbie adding Oppenheimer and
getting
Oppenheimer day is fast approaching how
will you be celebrating basically ever
since it was announced the two movies
would be released on the same day and
going head-to-head people have been
having fun with it the Barbie movie is a
light comedy
[Applause]
a matter of life and death Oppenheimer
about as heavy a drama as possible I
don't have anything big planned just
becoming deaf the destroyer of worlds
together they have trailers movie
posters and t-shirts people are showing
up with them in the red carpet okay I
have to sign it on this side
now it is something that casts of the
two movies seemingly half of Hollywood
by the way are enjoying marketing
experts say both will likely get a boost
at the box office from all the publicity
the world some theaters are promoting a
double bill but remember this day who
movies back to back which raises an
interesting question Barbie or
Oppenheimer which one do you think I'll
prefer no I mean which one do you want
to watch first I think the world maybe
wants to see Barbie a little bit more
right now I think actually start your
day with Bobby then go straight into
Oppenheimer and then Bobby Chaser why
are these men looking at me there is one
theater chain offering a discount for
people who see both but warning against
going back to back it's not just that
they'd run a combined five hours you are
the man who gave them the power to
destroy themselves the company says the
sudden change in subject matter might
lead to a sort of cinematic whiplash
Mike Armstrong Global News
I like the Barbie Chaser idea that's
global national for this Wednesday night
I'm Farah Nasser on behalf of our whole
crew I want to thank you so much for
spending part of your evening with us
and tonight's your Canada is the devil's
punch bowl in Spruce Woods Provincial
Park in Manitoba we love seeing your
Canada please keep emailing us your
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
until tomorrow take care of yourselves
and take care of each other good night
[Music]
thank you